i went there
to egypt and it confirmed what i was
already highly suspicious of which is
that something spectacular was happening
on earth that humans were doing amazing
things and it confirmed it whether it's
the assyrian for sure um
the sierpin with the center time boxes
the great pyramid and everything else
i'm like okay but in the great pyramid
in the king's chamber the frequency was
really high i just think they were
energy centers i think that perhaps they
were used for healing
um perhaps they were used to somehow
sort of charge up in some kind of ways
even to rebalance and maybe there was i
don't know communication with other
extraterrestrials maybe that's where it
happened because of the alignment with
orion's belt and the pyramids and and
the way that they use the stars perhaps
as sort of like a almost like a like a
direction it's like directions it's like
a map it's like oh yeah it could be land
here like we're here yeah ping ping like
land here come come and get us hey hey
alien overlords that dropped us off and
left us